voilà ça va prendre du temps euh général
de l'or pour que ces engins puissent
arriver sur les terrains de guerre vous
diriez que ce sont des annonces plus à
but politique que militaire
ok clairement il y a un problème de but
de guerre il est le président de ski lui
l'a exprimé de manière la plus rapide
possible c'est la reprise totale des
territoires Ukrainiens y compris la
Crimée donc du côté des de l'OTAN
l'expression est claire aussi c'est le
respect des frontières internationales
c'est aussi le fait que la Russie ne
doit pas gagner et que l'Ukraine ne doit
pas perdre donc avec cette expression là
arrive le soutien militaire il est déjà
très important il continue à s'amplifier
et là manifestement les services de
renseignement a principalement
américains ont dû noter que la
possibilité d'une offensive russe à la
fin du printemps était réel et donc
les gens du évaluer que la régénération
de des forces russes étaient telles que
la menace devait être prise en compte
donc je pense que c'est ça ce qui a
amené des Américains particulièrement
réticents au départ a donné un feu vert
qui s'est qui s'est si j'ose dire par
contagion à atteint Berlin et donc a
permis à la fois l'accord des Allemands
et puis l'accord des Américains mais en
fait c'est bien dans le sens américain
d'abord qu'il faut qu'il faut
l'interpréter car c'est eux qui assez
logiquement et de manière évidente
supporte l'essentiel du soutien
militaire à l'Ukraine dans dans le
conflit en cours contagion qui
visiblement n'a pas atteint la France
qui ne s'engage pas avec eux c'est
Charles Leclerc pour quelle raison alors
là
un nombre de charges réduit et puis je
crois qu'il y a aussi à le fait c'est
que
nous serions pas en mesure de remplacer
les chars qui seraient donnés à
l'Ukraine et qui serait sans doute
engagés vraiment au combat et peut-être
qu'il disparaîtrait et donc c'est
peut-être les Français réfléchissent
peut-être à une autre façon d'aider
militairement l'Ukraine avec des
équipements que nous serions capables de
renouveler par nous-mêmes mais la
fabrication des chars Leclerc est
arrêtée depuis 2008 et donc par contre
on a d'autres lignes de l'armement qui
fonctionnent
par exemple César César on était
évidemment est une forme de ces
équipements mais il y en a d'autres
domicile etc et donc là on peut
peut-être apporter à un soutien qui
serait très important et qui en tout cas
il faut plan politique et non
négligeable pour l'armée ukrainienne
on sent une certaine fébrilité alors
c'est vrai que la c'est livraison et ses
annonces ont pris beaucoup de temps en
plusieurs semaines pour que les
Américains et les Allemands donnent leur
feu vert là à l'instant Paris dit que ni
la France les partenaires ne sont en
guerre contre la Russie et le Kremlin
lui à l'inverse dénonce l'engagement
direct de l'Occident dans le conflit
est-ce qu'ils nous considère comme
kobiligérant ou et où mettre la ligne
rouge finalement
je crois que effectivement il faut faire
attention à
l'évolution du langage
langage du côté russe et
escalade
puisque
[Musique]
ils affirme
les pays de l'OTAN sont
je pense que c'est hâtif mais
effectivement il faut être très attentif
à ça je pense que notre président
Emmanuel Macron l'a exprimé il y a
quelques jours sur le fait qu'il faut
éviter d'aller à une guerre à une guerre
mondiale parce que en fait si
l'engagement de l'OTAN contre la Russie
c'est ça mènerait une guerre mondiale
c'est évidemment ce type de catastrophe
qu'il faut éviter alors comment était au
maximum l'Ukraine à se faire respecter
et à regagner ces territoires sans pour
autant s'engager dans un conflit être
poussé à un conflit avec la Russie et
déraisonnable
et d'ailleurs c'est pas une expression
vraiment qui est qui est on l'exprime de
la même façon à Washington à Berlin et à
Paris donc donc on voit bien que là les
trois grandes capitales et il y en a
d'autres mais les trois grandes
capitales de de représentants des pays
l'OTAN sont très attentifs à éviter
d'aller trop loin avec avec la Russie
pour éviter un conflit
serait par définition catastrophique et
pour les uns pour les autres et je pense
pas que ce soit le vœu des citoyens
européens américains donc on a bien
compris il y avait une ligne de crête
mais les Ukrainiens veulent aller plus
loin dans la livraison d'armes
occidentales notamment avec ces avions
de chasse les F-16 pour reprendre le
contrôle si j'ose dire du ciel
ukrainien et réclame aussi des missiles
à longue portée capables de frapper des
structures en territoire russe là ce
sera aller trop loin selon vous
des limites par définition ça se déplace
et là c'est les gens pensent aussi à
déplacer les frontières c'est pour ça
qu'il y a des guerres donc pour cette
limite là on peut penser qu'il y a déjà
des pilotes qui sont à l'entraînement
sur des F16 donc de façon à pas trop
perdre de temps si jamais une décision
politique de cette ampleur était prise
et d'autre part vous savez il y a un
exemple fameux de l'escadrer Lafayette
c'est à dire avant même l'entrée en
guerre des États-Unis pendant la
Première Guerre mondiale des jeunes
Américains étaient venus au sein de
l'escadrilles Lafayette sur comme pilote
d'avion contre contre l'Allemagne qui
avait envahi le nord de la France donc
pourquoi pas c'est une idée une idée
auquel on pourrait penser c'est que
aussi des pilotes formés sur F16 qui
pourrait éventuellement
agir profit d'Ukraine si ces matériels
aurait été délivrés mais il est bien
évident que là encore c'est
aux limites et je crois que là il en
revient complètement à aux autorités
politiques de définir l'effet qu'il
recherche
en tout cas ce qui est à peu près même
qui est absolument certain c'est qu'il
ne souhaite pas aller à une
confrontation avec la Russie car ça
serait désastreux catastrophique sans
doute pour les Russes mais aussi pour
les Européens et peut-être également
pour les Américains sachant que les
Européens nous sommes en première ligne
derrière l'Ukraine et que donc nous
sommes pas nous verrons nous sentir
particulièrement concerné par ce que par
la décision qu'ils ont prises parce que
l'engagement européen au profit de
l'Ukraine évidemment nous nous colle un
conflit qui est pas celui de l'Union
européenne qui est pas celui de le temps
mais qui est celle celui d'une
démocratie qui est qui est en pérenne
merci beaucoup général Dominique de
l'ordre d'avoir été notre invité par
Skype ancien chef du centre opérationnel
interarmé et je rappelle le titre de
votre